tu reviennes vacances
c'est quoi ce bronzage de folie
non parce qu'en fait je ne suis breton
donc je ne mets alors je connais plein
de bretons
comme une écrevisse donc je demande de
chauffer en haut non mais c'est rigoler
frère tu veux que je te dise là tu crois
que tu es bronzé
je me dis le reste deux heures à midi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sans charrier ça te va hyper bien mais
c'est gentil je veux comme montial parce
que c'est vrai qu'il est très très
maquillée
tu as quel âge toi j'ai 33 ans non c'est
pas vrai la moitié
on dirait déjà un vieux machin
merci non mais je te jure que c'est vrai
tous les matins je crois j'ai pas de la
barbe ou pas oui bien sûr
non parce que attention parce que lui
avec une barbe il peut très vite faire
en fait entrer l'accusé
attention quand même là
ça continue elle était déjà méchante
avec moi quand j'étais à l'école
continue
je rigole
mais oui je vois ça
ah bah là je comprends
non mais je me disais comment il fait
pour trouver des invités tous les matins
normal qu'il ait beaucoup d'inconnus
on a vu magicien
[Rires]
j'étais avec son assistant je vois
Patrick
il a parlé de celui qui a annoncé sa
carrière dans la glace à la comtesse du
Barry qu'il a lancé
dis moi et tu as des nouvelles de
champagne
ne me dis pas qui c'est juste dis-moi
les noms
il fait son grand retour
quand on est de retour chez Jordan de
luxe c'est qu'on a le temps non non je
rigole il est très drôle Maxime gros
talent j'adore ce mec on va faire
Marie-France et Giuseppe
la semaine dernière mais sans donne-moi
juste les prénoms ne me dis pas qui
c'est allez la semaine dernière Bernard
blinis donc d'accord donc c'est le
magicien je connais le magicien d'accord
en plus il est hyper sympa allez vas-y
Alexandre Alexandre Alexandre
taisez-vous Alexandre Alexandre c'est un
mec qui était dans ta classe
on a fait un peu de télé-réalité en fin
de semaine donc là ça va être compliqué
Sarah tu as réussi
mais je l'adore ça je l'adore ouais
après tu es avec qui on avait fait un
groupe qui faisait des gâteaux j'ai vu
là une meuf qui faisait des gâteaux
ça me fait plaisir c'est même pas qu'il
disait que c'est même pas qu'ils
écoutent ils ont gardé vraiment
l'émission là à la maison il a vu il a
dit il dit il a eu cette phrase
magnifique il a dit la même chose sur la
mission de Bernard Montiel il a dit
cette émission est vraiment éclaté au
sol
mais il t'adore il t'adore tu vois Cyril
non moi j'adore l'émission
j'ai plein de questions à vous poser
des fois je vous envoie des messages je
vous répondez dès que je vous demande de
venir j'ai plus de son plus d'image j'ai
tout simplement pas que ça euh
voilà maintenant comme ça tu as la
réponse voilà non mais c'est très bien
c'est 30 minutes on vous prend un taxi
aller-retour
non vous produisez le montage
tu peux c'est Delux production qui
produit oui on est trois associés je
vais récupérer ça
on est déjà chez vous alors toute façon
il est bon ou pas très content de le
voir je suis stressé j'étais c'est vrai
qu'il ne veut de Madame de Fontenay mais
non mais oh là là en plus je suis fâché
avec elle parce que cette histoire parce
que moi il s'est présenté comme ça au
départ parce que je en rabattage c'est
vrai elle était invité chez vous dans
les présences elle faisait le rabattage
non je vous explique ce que je l'avais
rencontré mais tu m'as menti alors
on peut pas vous avoir si on vous ment
pas
[Musique]
non mais j'avais arrangé
un peu la vérité pour vous avoir dit que
c'était le lever mais j'ai dit ça mais
ça a marché tu es de nouveau de qui et
je suis levé de personne moi c'est pas
comment ton oncle mon oncle Thierry
Thierry
chez PSA non non
alors comment il s'appelle
Didier Jean-Luc
une famille bretonne alors
pas du tout non non mais non j'ai pris
de luxe parce que je voulais pas laisser
Guinel les Guignols quand j'étais petit
tout le temps
l'enfer c'est un enfer je me suis dit je
vais ça va pas du coup que ça va
recommencer à la télé comment on prend
pour un con donc du coup
de luxe en allant un jour dans une
grande enseigne est-ce que j'ai été
manger un truc vous savez les Big Mac
Company et la fille quand elle m'a vendu
le burger on l'a dit alors celui-là
extraordinaire machin heureusement que
tu as pas été dans un kebab
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jordan
radio
dans un instant vous retrouverez le
goffeur qui sera avec nous salut c'est
Sunday tu nous appelles d'où salut
Didier ouais ouais Didier tu nous
appelles danger d'accord ouais Didier tu
sais quoi ton problème quoi tu as voulu
tes doigts ta meuf au McDo ouais
d'accord je connais les pleins pro ou
pas
mon ami que j'aime euh Cauet qui a fait
des bonnes oignons c'est Guillaume
chanton les hommes de radio le reste ne
vous gratter bon c'est oui alors sinon
parler de toi c'est comment s'appelle ta
mère et maman elle s'appelle Louisette
Louisette arrêtez avec ma mère aucun
truc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ne passons pas à côté des choses simples
Jordan
[Applaudissements]
c'est nous les gens on aime le jambon
arrêter cette vanne elle est nulle
un chanteur des années 80
sur le popotin
c'est parti c'est un fou ce Jean-Marc
tape-moi
tape-moi tape-moi sur le popotin
[Applaudissements]
salut moi c'est Jean-Marc
jean-marinel
Jean-Marc Guinet c'était pour ça
mais j'avais changé mon nom pour éviter
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est alors mon père il était gardien
déchetterie c'était pas facile quand
j'étais gardien de des déchets tu es
dans une déchètes
Deborah
les gens voilà ouais ouais c'était
compliqué pour moi quand j'étais petit
donc j'ai inventé des trucs il travaille
dans les espaces verts et tout sauf
qu'un jour
je me venge avec Valette
3 pour bien
j'ai un copain qui est allé déposer les
trucs une vieille télé il est tombée sur
mon père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu rigoles une fois maintenant je vous
raconte comment dire Jean-Michel maire
je vais avoir mis un texto pour je sais
plus quoi ce que c'était une connerie
machin et un jour il a montré je sais
pas pourquoi vous l'aviez emmerdé un
petit peu et il monte sur téléphone ce
que vous aviez à la caméra non mais
c'est pas une blague et il y avait un de
mes textos qui était dessus évidemment
il va pas enregistrer et on va utiliser
aussi 42 non 08 Pacha et avec les
replays et tout les gens ils font des
captures d'écran et je me suis fait mais
envoyer plein de messages parce que il
pensait que j'étais une copine de
Jean-Michel maire tu as toute anecdote
de genre dis-moi tu es en couple c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué parce que
sinon je vous pose des questions aussi à
dire que oui
c'est à dire que oui c'est Cyril vous
vous êtes en couple chérie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]